welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Loki season 2 at the end of season 1
Loki and Sylvie met the mysterious man
behind the TVA he who remains we know
he's King Sylvie wanted to free the
timeline from the tva's rule so she
killed him she kicked Loki back to the
TVA where his new best friend Mobius
doesn't remember him and Loki has
another problem wow he's slipping
through time he's slipping between the
present TVA and the past TVA when he who
remains still had a statue of himself
before he rebranded as the timekeepers
in the present TVA the sacred timeline
has been branching they've got a
Multiverse now now that they know the
timekeepers are fake they've stopped
pruning branches going to let them grow
now Loki slips back to the present and
fills them in about he who remains and
gives them the bad news about these new
timelines all the king variants will
have a multiversal war that destroys
everything but first they got to stop
Loki's time slipping so they go down to
maintenance and meet Ora Boris Obie for
short he doesn't know how to stop time
slipping but Loki just slipped to the
past and filled him in so he had a long
time to work on it and oh I do know how
to stop it they go to the core of the
TVA the temporal Loom mobus has to
venture outside and shoot an anchor into
the timeline then Loki has to prune
himself but oh he slips away right now
and is desperately searching for a prune
stick and he's surprised to find Sylvie
in an elevator then wow he's pruned from
behind more on this later but anyway it
works and Loki's back anchored in the
present so Loki and Mobius take a pie
break to figure out what to do next
while their other friends Hunter B15 and
the tech Casey go down to see Obie and
help him out but one TVA General goes
off on a mission to hunt down syby so
Loki and Mobius got to track down one of
her Hunters who has now left for a life
on the timeline as a 70s movie star
convince him to tell them sylv's
location she's working at a McDonald's
in the 1980s so our Loki variant love
birds have a chat the TBA needs your
help I don't care I just want to live a
normal life but right now that Rogue
General is trying to prune this timeline
as well as a bunch of others so silby
asked to help put a stop to that now
there's a new problem with judge Ren
Slayer who's working with Miss minutes
on a contingency plan from he who
remains they drop a TVA handbook into
the window of this kid from the 1800s
Loki and Mobius follow her Trail which
leads to the 1893 Chicago World's Fair
that kid has grown up into Victor timely
an eccentric inventor who Loki
recognizes as a variant of he who
remains so all our time travelers are
fighting to get him it turns into a
whole thing Sylvie wants to kill him so
he can't become another he who remains
but he's like yo that guy wasn't me and
as a variant herself Sylvie understands
so she lets him live and kicks R Slayer
out of there now they need Victor timy's
help to save the TVA because the
temporal Loom is overloading it wasn't
designed to handle multiple timelines
he's excited to meet the Ora Boris who
wrote the TBA handbook but turns out
Obie only wrote it based on notes from
Victor timley wo time Paradox so
together they invent the science thing
that will let the loom have multiple
timelines meanwhile renair and Miss
minut are at the end of time where Miss
minut fills her in on who she was before
the TVA she was his top General who
basically won the king War for him they
were supposed to rule the sacred
timeline together but he erased her
memory just like everyone else's so now
she's real mad she and Miss minutes
capture Victor timely they're going to
lead a TVA coup Loki's running to stop
them but first he runs into his past
self so oh he prunes himself Classic
Time Paradox now they save Victor timely
Sylvie mind controls the movie star who
prunes Ren Slayer but remember when
you're pruned you're just sent to the
end of time so Ren Slayer is still
kicking around out there but now they
got a rush to do the science thing to
stop the temporal Loom from overloading
Victor timley goes out there for his big
hero moment but oh it doesn't work he's
ripped to shreds yeah they just took too
long and now the loom explodes and the
TVA is destroyed but Loki's okay for
some reason he starts time slipping
again he slips to a Jet Ski Store yeah
remember Mobius loves jet skis his real
life was a jet ski salesman Loki's like
Mobius I need your help to save the
timeline but it's like who's Mobius my
name's Dawn now Loki slips over to Obie
who's not a scientist he's a failed
science fiction writer but he does have
a degree in theoretical physics so he's
able to learn about time travel from the
TVA handbook that he would eventually
write time Paradox so in a few years of
his time but one minute of Loki Obi
invents a tempat and they go back to see
obus it's like dude I know you have a
life and kids but you're the only one
who can save the Multiverse and you
won't miss anything cuz with time travel
we'll bring you right back here when
it's all done so Loki recruits all his
friends from their lives on the timeline
but his last recruit is Sylvie who
doesn't want to help she's like the
Multiverse is better off without the TVA
but turns out it's not without the
temporal Loom powering the timelines
they're all fading away and so this is
it it's the end of everything until Loki
learns to control his time slipping he
travels back to the moment they're
saving the loom like yo we got to go
faster this time and so it's time for a
classic time Loop where Loki red do this
over and over again but it always fails
so L tries going back earlier in the day
to help them invent the science thing
faster finally he realizes it'll just be
faster if they teach him how to build it
they're like uh we don't have time for
that but he's like trust me we do and so
centuries later we catch up with Master
scientist Loki who's able to get him out
there real quick he guides them through
all the problems that have gone wrong
over thousands of Loops but this one is
it they actually do it the day is saved
except it's not the loom is still
overloading they realize because the
timelines are growing infinitely no
matter matter how much they increase the
Looms capacity it will never be enough
so now Loki has to go back even further
to the end of season 1 and stop Sylvie
from killing he who remains he tries to
tell her killing him won't work it just
ends up destroying the universe but this
past Sylvie doesn't believe him she
always goes and kills him anyway
eventually he who remains steps in so
Loki how many Loops is this for you yeah
he's aware of the whole situation he
explains how the temporal Loom
overloading is part of its design so
that even if he dies it'll lead them
right back here he's like look Loki
can't save the Multiverse the only
options are the TVA with my sacred
timeline or nothing but Loki comes up
with one other option a drastic one but
the only way to save his friends he
walks on out there himself yeah remember
as an Asgardian God he can take it he
destroys the loom before it can overload
but this still leaves all the timelines
dying but they don't need the energy
from the loom Loki can power them with
his own magic but it won't last without
him holding them Loki has to stay out
here so he grabs all the timelines and
takes takes the throne at the end of
time which ironically was Loki's
original selfish plan to take the throne
and Rule all of time but instead Loki
finds his new glorious purpose is not to
rule but to protect he uses himself to
power the timelines allowing a
Multiverse to flourish in fact this new
Multiverse looks like a tree igdrasil
the world tree of Norse mythology and so
the TVA has rebuilt with a rebooted
non-evil Mis minutes and their new
mission is not to prune timelines but to
let them flourish and just keep an eye
on it specifically they're watching for
any Kang variant to nip any multiversal
wars in the bud everything seems to be
under control and so agent Mobius is
ready to retire time to go home to his
sons and his sidus and Sylvie is now
finally free to go live whatever normal
life she wants but this happy ending is
bittersweet because it's all made
possible by Loki our new god of time
sacrificing himself by sitting here for
eternity a real lonely existence and
that's how Loki season 2 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and
movies